[Music]
oh hello hi welcome to us trailer
commentaries uh the show where we will
do a in-depth deep dive into every james
connery james connery wow
sean connery james bond uh why hasn't
james kahn ever played james bond i feel
like scott khan i think horse guy one of
the cons fake scott khan bond uh we're
gonna watch the trailer together we're
gonna catch some deleted scenes we'll
answer questions and comments from all
of you just keep those coming in the
chat we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer it's seasonal you'll love
it um i'm here with lon lon the just two
boys talking bond today uh
cracking open a snifter brandy from a
very particular year that we can tell
with our nose
no it's a sherry
sherry's usually don't have a year but
bond can tell the vintage of the grape
that was turned into the sheriff you see
how much refinement in that uh that's
that
killing and effing machine um he sure
knew his vintage uh and yeah i mean
let's talk let's open it up it's like
what was it like to revisit films that i
i've certainly seen multiple times and
what's your what's your bond history and
how did you feel on this rewatch i'm a
big i'm a big fan of the buns this was
my dad was not very into movies when i
was growing up so this was not like i
got really into movies this was not a
thing that we shared except
he loves bond and like spy stuff so this
was like one of the few things that my
dad and i in terms of movies could
really enjoy together so i always grew
up enjoying this series in particular i
you know i was like
impressionable and in high school and
really getting into movies during the
peak brosnan era so i love the golden
eye and uh i still think like tomorrow
and everytime's world is not enough fun
i enjoy this um
so i got when the when the the blu-ray
box set of all the bonds came out like
right around the time spectre hit
theaters i think i bought that and i
marathoned the whole thing so that was
the last time i'd watched the connery's
until we made this on his trailer so i
was already fairly
yeah and you know i've never watched
them all in order and sat down and
watched it from the beginning it was
always kind of hodgepodge growing up
like i'd see it there's brows and one in
in theaters and then i go see a random
roger more one on tnt or exactly it's
like they're doing a bond marathon and
you happen to tune in during for your
eyes only and it's like well i'm
watching this one now
it was super interesting to see it
evolve you know from from dr no onward
uh as far as the the tropes kind of
solidifying and like taking their final
form slowly and also just like watching
action cinema evolve like what passed
for an action sequence in dr dale what
passed for an action sequence in and
also like you only live twice which is
my favorite bond it turns out
oh yeah for sure that one to me
goldfinger and and uh you only live
twice are like clearly the high water
mark of the connery era all the others
are there's stuff i like in them but
those two really stand out and they were
not well regarded well goldfinger was
but the only of choice was not well
regarded in its time um because it's
like super baroque and it's like you
have to hold the volcano layers and the
cheesiness and the over the top yeah
everything about that
rooms full of ninjas and yet uh i think
in hindsight that's what's fun about old
james bond is like the goofy stuff um
yeah
what we respond to especially in the
like post austin powers era
is like that the very mod the the over
the top almost cartoonish level of it is
what we sort of remember best you know
like there's a laser coming and it's
about to hit his crotch
you know like like that stuff and i
think that's what those two movies
capture better than some of the others
that are more you know like the ian
fleming books where they're a little bit
more serious and they're really kind of
trying to be about this cool spy instead
of making it you know silly and campy
and yeah but even though it was silly
and campy you know it's of an era where
they had to either build everything
themselves or find real locations it's
just a cool snapshot of the world in the
60s um of like the amazing places they
could find and and stick bond in or the
weird the actual layers that they would
have to build on a sound stage i guess i
don't know they didn't actually find a
volcano but
just
almost all of those are just ken adam
decorated a sound stage and they made it
look as impressive as they as they
possibly could yeah so i don't know
that's one cool thing about going
through the whole series is that it
really does track just the development
and evolution of action movies like
they're always kind of interacting with
whatever was going on at the time like
live and let die has like a
blaxploitation sort of flavor because
that was what was in the culture even to
the craigs like you know casino royale
has that whole parkour sequence because
everything was parkour and definitely
born born franchise influenced and yeah
if we kept going through roger moore
like moonraker is basically like well
what if bond did a star war right
and they're and they're consistently
like that through the whole history of
the series which is fun now to go back
because you kind of get these snapshots
of all these different errors like
thunderball obviously you could tell
there were breakthroughs in underwater
photography like it's so obvious that
they got this equipment they were so
excited to use they were like should
should we pick up the pace on this
20-minute scuba diving sequence no
people be fascinated they've never been
under the water before right it's like
it uh it was reminding me of uh the very
first star trek movie star trek the
motion picture oh my god a spaceship
right 20 minutes of kirk just going out
to get on the enterprise because they
were so blown away by what they could do
in terms of like models and
photography they're certainly
deliberately paced all of these films
they get quicker but um boy are they
slow by modern standards um we mentioned
i saw some other people talk about this
uh how much hotel stuff i know pops up
in the trailer there is so much hotel
stuff
you always forget that part part of the
allure of bond is checking into your
hotel yeah i guess in the 60s it was
still like an exotic like a lot of
people like had never checked into a
hotel and wanted to see what it what it
is like
well we'll see we'll see all that and
more let's start and stop as we go
through the trailer for every sean
connery james bond
roll it
most scottish man
now that daniel craig has finally earned
some time to die revisit the six
canonical films of the
best damn
james not you bond ever
doesn't count
so we should pause
well first of all amazing graphics by
robert holtby per usual um bravo yeah uh
you know he's in the uk he has to do his
his motherland proud
james bond this is a real time to shine
for him yeah yeah
he's prepped he already had these ready
to go when we asked him because he's got
a title for every classic film and uh
yeah
um to explain that joke uh her majesty's
secret service was like a sean connery
retired and then came back right so
that's this one-off uh uh aberration
australian george lazenby play yeah
english secret agent which is getting
it's it's deserved uh reevaluation i
think that's a really good bond that
that tells you a lot about the modern
ones and then uh the the uh never say
never again one is this weird like
rights dispute where they made
thunderball twice and they just dropped
a boatload of money in john connery's
lap but there was also roger moore was
already james bond and doing his own
thing yeah basically
ian fleming had an idea for thunderball
which he was going to write as a bond
book but then they just he was like he
didn't get around to writing the book
and they ended up turning that into the
movie thunderball but then later he was
still like well i'm still it's my story
i'm going to turn it into a book anyway
so it was always back and forth about
who owns
thunderball does it just belong to ian
fleming does it belong to the people who
wrote that movie with him does it belong
to eon productions blah blah blah blah
blah so
all kinds of legal disputes that's as
far as i think we need to unpack it but
there were all always different
companies that felt like well maybe i
could get in on this angle on james bond
because it's not part of that cannon
that that company owns yeah casino right
now in the 60s with david niven yeah
it's odd and it's it's definitely the
result of a rights dispute and if you
watch it also thunderball again it's the
same story
right so if we were to include that we
would just say thunderball um but older
which is not a not the story that you're
like let's repeat that one
oh boy
um but uh yes and well they did some
different things but not enough to
really warrant talking about uh let's
continue like a remake of thunderball
it's just not different enough and
connery's getting a little long in the
long and the tooth yeah although all
bonds tend to like get old in the role
maybe it's like a thing that
okay let's keep watching
sean connery stars as james bond
england's most scottish spy i'm a very
nervous passenger a secret agent who was
already too over this by a second outing
whatever you say old man but james
brings a unique set of skills to the
table like being famous my god you just
killed james bond
ah disguise fighting like your drunk
stepdad
yeah
there are so many fights in uh
across this uh early series where it's
just james bond just brawling he's just
like a caveman like throwing furniture
in the other game
grunting
this may be the biggest change in like
how action is shot like basically in
2021 action movies everyone knows
martial arts like in the fast and
furious movies you could just pick it up
by watching people like and start
kicking ass like almost immediately yeah
uh and in these movies it's very like
most people don't really know how to
fight no they all look like bar fights
which is i guess realistic yeah they're
just two drunk europeans just grappling
with each other i mean like that's what
i would be like in a fight like i'm not
gonna like suddenly like i don't know
how to do like tiger style or whatever
like if somebody tries to hit me i'm
just gonna like grab their legs
to be fair what's funny about it is that
they are uh they're fighting like two
dads outside a little league game but
then it'll cut to like a single judo
chop and then that'll be what ends the
fight it's like he remembers his judo
it'll do like one little wrist lock and
it'll end because
they are not regular they're like
assassins and spies and like you would
think they would have had fight training
or whatever which is not a thing that
would actually i mean even the most
highly trained fighters you know you
watch ufc and it's mostly like people
just wrestling on the ground right just
like
hitting the back of the head until you
like get disoriented yeah yeah um so
thrilling stuff
okay keep going all-time greatest
baccaratters
baccaratists baccarat guys
yeah no clue what's going on here this
game might as well be quidditch
won't
i think you try to get closest to nine i
think and you're like it's like
blackjack but it's like who's who's can
get to nine
i i i'm that's all i know
all i know is it's like you you bet with
you don't have chips you have like
plates like weird little like card
shaped yes like medallions and there's a
shoe they like passed around like a yeah
they've got like a board
right it's a very i mean it looks made
up like it looks like a fantasy movie
game that they're playing like it's
dejarik or something yeah it's like well
all right i i guess i'll just go with it
i mean didn't they they the the craig
films they change it to poker right to
texas hold'em
yes well in casino royale he's playing
in a texas hold'em like tournament and i
that's what i love is this scene
baccarat a game not a lot of americans
know how to play no explanation as to
how the game works but texas hold'em a
game basically everybody understands
they still feel they need to have
jeffrey wright explain the entire game
to even green and then yeah i think
that's another thing they'll miss
so they'll bet they'll have if you're
going to explain the card game anyways
just explain background i wish i knew
how it worked to be right
if you're good exactly it's like have
jeffrey wright explain to me buck right
actually i've gotten something out of
that scene
oh well remake casino or the next bond
bring it up honestly just like somebody
hired jeffrey right to just explain
baccarat to me like make it make it a
one-off youtube video welcome to my
master class
this is the shoe uh okay
joining him is m a character you could
easily replace with a self-destructing
tape player from mission impossible q
the only mad scientist on bonsai
who gives him every gadget from
chekhov's poison briefcase to chekhov's
helicopter briefcase miss moneypenny
proof that mi6 may have an m and a q but
it's definitely missing an h and an r
next time i see you i'll put you across
my knee on yogurt and lemon juice
i can hardly wait
what what does that mean on yogurt and
lemon juice no idea no i had no idea
it's the way she says it i know it's
something extremely horny but is can
maybe some of our uk uh viewers i feel
like this is either this is either a uk
thing or it's a 60s thing like is it
like this was a thing women were eating
or there was some sort of thing you were
supposed to do with yogurt lemon juice
in that era or it's a british expression
that we just not understand yeah my only
hunch is it's like um like cockney
rhyming slang as i learned from ocean's
11 we're in barney barney rubble trouble
is there anything that rhymes with that
i was wracking my brain and it just it's
just a weird horny non-sequiturs that's
all i came up with yeah i don't think
it's like apples and pears and stairs
but i don't know what yogurt and lemon
juice would mean that it's very strange
anyways money penny uh hornier than
james bond which is saying something
don't ever say that to your boss's
receptionist folks
because they're going to come out and
just say you ever happen to be talking
to your boss's receptionist and you're
like i'll see you soon don't don't don't
threaten to put them over your knee
all right keep playing lucky girl james
traps on his sex boat at the end of each
film they can't refuse because of the
implication
but no matter how great the risk if you
help james bond accomplish his mission
he will never let you get killed don't
worry quarrel everything's going to be
fine
okay maybe once
i think they parodied that scene in
austin powers or something like that
because that is the most slowly
advancing
tank flamethrower of death
put to cinema yeah he could move
any direction at any time and that tank
just slowly rolls up to him before it
hits him with the flamethrower it's it's
beautiful i love that several characters
in the film expressed their fervent
belief that that is a real dragon dragon
and then you see it from very far away
yeah very clearly a true no that's
someone painted teeth on it there's a
tank or a truck that is that is not an
animal what is wrong with you
no one would make this mistake yeah one
of the sillier smaller moments but that
was the first one right that was dr no
that's dr noah yeah so that was and
that's probably i haven't read dr no the
book but that might be that's probably
take it i bet that's in the book yeah it
re it reads better on the page right you
see that's very clearly uh a jeep with i
think the technology maybe wasn't there
to make it more realistic yeah i did the
best for what they could yeah um all
right keep playing
they killed each other once or twice you
wanted to ask me some questions
okay
constantly oh hey it almost looked like
you cared about her oh you know what
that's called character growth
set off on your typical connery bond
adventure that begins with a lounger
bursting a blood vessel
this is a
debated uh story i can't quite track
down whether it's true or not that tom
jones actually passed out when he hit
that note
that's a it's like an urban legend that
tom just hit the high note in
thunderball and then collapsed literally
in the the sound booth but i don't i
don't know if that's true yeah i'd like
to think that it's true i think tom
jones doesn't get enough uh enough love
these days i saw i had an i had an ex
who really loved tom jones and i went
and saw him so i've seen him live at the
at the hollywood bowl and he he's a very
old man now and he still like does the
sexy dancings and like rips his shirt
open with the chest hair and women still
like throw things on stage for him like
it is that the the bit has not changed
since the heyday of time that's amazing
yeah i saw somebody like tony bennett i
saw like i don't know five ten years ago
he was already very old and can still
sing like uh like a top vegas show pony
lamp singer it's great just was amazing
he did like what's new pussycat she's a
lady and like all the all the classics
next bombs next bomb's my favorite yeah
did not do thunderball though
yeah all right anyways keep playing the
most exotic locales you can pretend to
drive through where bond will track the
bad guy to their bachelor pad of evil
quip on the stillwarm grave of their
henchmen oh he blew a fuse
then take down the real threat a rich
european man with the physique of an egg
this is the ideal evil body you may not
like it but this is what peak evil
performance looks like
in between us
he would actually have to fight these
guys at the end of the film and it's a
little bit of like the john wick problem
where like once you've dispatched all
the all the henchmen and the underlings
and the super martial artists they
deployed to stop you then you have to
fight like the old russian crime boss
again somehow
it just never makes for uh for the best
conclusion it's always more exciting to
watch him fight odd job or jaws right
the the underlings with the special
powers the classic move in a lot of
movies that they'll do is like the he's
not a he's not a looming physical threat
the main bad guy but he'll like grab a
key hostage you know so it's like well
he's got the girl so what are you gonna
do now hot shot uh bon he usually does
not go that way all right like the bad
guy has already murdered whoever james
was with for the duration of the movie
uh and so yeah they just have to like he
has to just like fight this like 50 year
old german man
how all good things come to an end yeah
um
all right keep playing do you remember
do you expect me to talk oh mr bond i
expect you to die
settle in for all the classic busy work
you forgot these old movies were full of
as you joined bond on a marathon of
exciting meetings briefings and
interviews the prime minister and the
president
have talked together over the hotline
and
have agreed
that unless the bombs are recovered
payment will have to be made watch him
meticulously
there's a ton of in these early films uh
actual intelligence gathering legwork
and
sure that does fill in the gaps of how
james bond came to uncover the issue and
exactly who told him what and what he
knew it every time but it is very slow
going they did not master doing like
something else on screen while
exposition is being like snuck in it's
really just james bond talking to people
in like one-on-one meetings for a lot of
it with not much else happening yeah
there's also there's always this weird
unexplained like in the newer bond
movies they explain the weird like
hostility between like em and bond you
know like judy dench it was always like
you're a dinosaur you're from the cold
war you're not how we do things anymore
whatever but in these old movies they
just don't like each other and it's
never really unpacked they're just both
irritated by one another the whole time
i mean i picked up that uh that james
was like just unreliable and he would
kind of drop off the map he's the best
yeah he's one of their best men but like
he's always you know in the middle of
partying or gambling or drinking or with
some woman when they when he gets called
in and you can tell em just doesn't uh
uh sanction that buffoonery i guess i
don't know it's just like you know i
always wait for it to get like to raise
the stakes or something and it's just
like nope they're just kind of they're
just kind of
passive-aggressive at work yeah well
weird [ __ ] you know he's not good at
what he does i mean he's good because he
always wins at the end yes there isn't
what he does except for wolverine but
he's always getting sidetracked by uh by
you know what
i'm constantly listen he loves the
ladies he loves the ladies as we'll talk
about
uh sometimes you have to take a break
from your important spy work to go
settle a dispute at a gypsy camp
whoever your target is i find it's best
to first have sex with their girlfriend
and then
yeah then things really come to a
conclusion uh much more simply all right
uh keep playing grooms
[Music]
spycraft
yeah
yep
it's bugged gotta gotta check
all that
stuff out
[Music]
get driving directions you leave the
port royal road out of kingston then
along the windward road until you get to
the cement factory then you turn left
follow the road up the hill down the
other side otherwise i'd be wondering
how he got there check into his
hotel we're here to make your stay as
pleasant as possible that's really most
kind of you do we really need this part
mr bond your room is ready we do my key
it's 304 please thank you again oh my
god the knight respond
well i think it's about hotel time why
return to a time i mean i guess it's
just it's part and parcel of the the
appeal of these movies is it's
globetrotting but we just don't need to
see
the
specifics of how he's got his room like
the exotic the the little cows like
shooting on location like when he's at
the pyramids like that's there in tokyo
you know like that's the exciting stuff
about globetrotting that you could shoot
the hotel we know that that's not
soundstage
start with him entering the hotel room
shepparton studios or whatever hey
where'd he get that room key it was like
we could surmise that there was somebody
at the front desk who greeted him and
took his bags like i don't know i can
assume that part yeah it's
it was more exciting back then to to go
visit a hotel it was not a thing people
were doing all the time and they were
just really it was like wish fulfillment
fantasy escapism yeah one day i'm gonna
go to a hotel and somebody's gonna call
me sir
yeah the next bond is just gonna be like
uh flipping through uh like expedia or
like hotels.com links like trying to try
to find an open room
[Laughter]
i know we're not ready for comments yet
but people are correcting how dumb we're
being it's because he's bond's at a spa
so she's saying you're only eating
yogurt and lemon juice you'll be too
weak to spank
that's the explanation you're on yogurt
and lemon juice as in like you're on a
diet right he's at a health spot we
weren't thinking about this because
those aren't really that's not what you
need at a health spot not only is it not
a health spot thing but it's the context
of what she's like i'll have you over my
knee her response is on yogurt and lemon
juice as in like she would cover herself
in yogurt right that's what we were
thinking but no she's saying you're only
eating a diet of yogurt and lemon juice
you'll be totally how are you going to
spank me you won't be able to properly
give me a proper spanking
oh
i think they're right i don't think
that's like a good it's not good writing
but i agree with it it does make sense
that doesn't it mystery song
i think that's the correct answer yeah
okay great now i have that image
perfectly burned into my redness um all
right let's keep playing was a drunken
chainsmoker so it didn't take too much
to knock him out cold
and oh
[Music]
very well well done guys i didn't say
pause i just
they all they'll collect to the point
where being a sober incel gave you super
powers vargas does not drink
does not smoke
does not make love and watch james take
on spectre the vegans giving journalism
and that is
special executive for counter
intelligence terrorism revenge extortion
oh i'm now working for spectrum spectre
always delivers what it promises welcome
to spectre island these illuminati's
have an evil planet
the space program steal nuclear missiles
and
well they just kind of ping-pong between
those two plans there's a real brain
drain when you keep killing your
co-workers
yeah pause and like spector's whole uh
uh modus operandi was that they uh it's
smarter it's like a a more impressive
feat of intelligence to do great
criminal things rather than great
law-abiding things but they don't seem
very smart they seem uh they seem kind
of basic uh not gonna lie
it's just like they it
it's so weird that it's like this weird
self-fulfilling thing like what are they
after and then it's like well money i
guess but then they're using the money
to fund their evil projects but then the
evil projects are always about embedded
like bilking someone for money or
blackmailing someone funny it's like
what's the what's that i think it is
about i think they say it in doctor
knows like it's about showing off and
like showing that you're the smartest
dude around like pulling off these
schemes it's it's cobra like it's it's
gi joe and cobra have the same
relationship as mi6 inspector where it's
like they basically just exist to be
counter forces they're not and neither
of them are really trying to progress
anywhere they're just there to like be a
rival for the other no it's a it's a
dangerous game um
that keeps them all employed
um all right it also seems like it would
you would not like working for spectre
is like what do i get out of this other
than if i don't do a good job i'm
immediately murdered
i don't know why do people work at
spacex or a deaf place
working for elon musk might not be great
but if you disappoint him he does not
just shoot you on these parts simply lie
you're right here i don't think so
no he totally doesn't do that parody
parody parody uh all right keep playing
but it's the bond girls who give him a
license to say
every girl jinx meets along the way has
the shape of an hourglass and the name
of a drag queen silvia trench plenty of
tools [ __ ] galore honey
what's so funny about it and whether
they get to be a character with their
own motives and agenda or a sexy baby
who just kind of washes up on shore bond
will get them into bed with little more
than a look all the things i do for
england
except for the times when he has to
force them
[Music]
yeah the romantic music is not helping
or blackmail them i'd lose my job i
suppose my silence could have a price
you don't mean
and that's before he smacks them around
a little
though how much of this is bond and how
much is constant we'll never know
i know we say how much this is bond and
how much this is donnery but like
do you know how much do you know about
ian fleming's marriage and like
relationship throughout his life because
it's
crazy if you want to know i don't really
know about this i don't have like the
notes in front of me to give like a true
deep dive but it was like a very like a
decades-long affair with his eventual
wife who was like part of high society
and he wasn't and they had like a
s m tinged affair for uh a very long
time with some very interesting power
dynamics that kind of inform
why james bond might
[Music]
cost women and also get tied up a lot
himself it's really interesting
there's that we included in this montage
i like couldn't believe what i was
watching diamonds are forever open for
the whole montage it's like the opening
before the you know he shoots into the
gun or whatever uh and it's it's him
just going around beating people up
asking where's blofeld like he's just
like you don't even see bot you just see
like his fists coming like where is bro
from smack and uh there's a shot of him
on the beach and he walks up to this
random woman we have no context on who
she is he grabs her he grabs off her
bikini top and uses it as like handcuffs
to to tie her up yeah first of all how
do you even realize you can do that like
did he practice that maneuver
q has like a like a yeah a mannequin
yeah now see here seven you grab the
brawl behind the strap and you like it's
a boy it's such a bizarre it's a really
yeah it's a fetishized thing it's insane
so uh if you're interested go go read
the letters between ian fleming and his
wife uh throughout the years they're
very they're very uh
sure i will add when lanawood introduces
herself as plenty of tool james's
response is named for your father
perhaps like is that a joke about her
father's uh genitals
saying her dad had plenty of tools
i don't know we have ryan o'toole our
producer ryan what do you think
uh yeah that's how it's carried down
yeah
that's a weird thing to say to somebody
you've just met even in a flirtatious
way like even as innuendo that's like
i get that all the time that's just
that's something that people think about
talking about your father's
[Laughter]
okay uh let's keep going
to give a good slap yeah absolutely
yikes
so enjoy this iconic defender of the
empire responsible for most of the
world's problems in an english fantasy
where they're still at the center of
geopolitics as we salute this heroic
dinosaur who simply refuses to go
extinct no matter how many times he
should have been killed by spectre
or liver disease i told the stewardess
liquor for three who are the other two
oh there are no other two or chlamydia
they're both yours or parody yeah baby
yeah or bankruptcy unfortunately they
ran out of money or swedish humping
machine
[Music]
or just plain older robins that's as bad
as listening to the beatles
we all keep coming back for more and by
more i mean lazenby then connery then
more craig brosnan dalton yeah that's my
ranking fight pause that being a little
bit trollish because uh i just think
he's underrated and i would put him
one a and one b with connery but uh but
you know gotta put it in the form of a
joke so there you go i just really don't
like this because it's very unfair to
dalton it was terrific and i like both
of his there are a lot of dalton dalton
stands um i think it's an age like we're
in the era now where people like me grew
up watching the daltons and so there's a
lot of fondness for them there but i i
mean that's a great example of just what
we were talking about how
they're very 80s like licensed to kill
almost has like a miami vice kind of
vibe to it i think they go to my it's
like a miami drug dealer yeah it's like
they're right there they're it's bond
versus like a cartel uh yeah and yeah
like so i think that that stuff is a lot
of fun
so what is the next bond gonna be to
it's probably gonna have to be like the
mcu will probably be a superhero or
something like that like what are these
next ones already basically
i personally i would love for them to uh
go like go back in time like if you're
gonna start over with a new bond anyway
just like make it the 60s again and we
could do cold war stories and make the
soviets to bad guys and like wouldn't
that be fun like that basically yeah
like a run of three or four movies where
we just like don't have to worry about
who's the villain like oh it's a tech
mogul north korea like you know like the
world now is not as fun for this kind of
story but when we talk about this uh
yesterday was this bond we were talking
about it should be set in 1999
he's right yes he's he's he's at
woodstock 99.
[Applause]
like listening to a limp brisket without
earmuffs
i did it all for the nookie
all right uh we're almost done let's
keep going
staring
me two below seven
judy dench origins tinker taylor older
guy
simbat dr no
daniel craig i love gold
blow hard
you can't play his odd job he's shorter
that's cheating
dick fury
fellas is it gay to try to assassinate
james bond with your bros
[Music]
i'll show you
nature you scary waits until the
survivor is so exhausted that he cannot
defend himself
you will see that my piranha fish get
very hungry
[Music]
pause the way to kill james bond was to
was it a trained
spider or was it just a tarantula just
put a tarantula in his hotel room and
let nature take its course like that
that'll definitely take care of it i
can't imagine that waking anybody up a
massive airy spider crawling on them
just a very long sequence of a spider
crawling on his bed and then he just
hammers it to death with a shoe um
actually i mean there's a lot of that's
one of the scenes i think that's there
to like lovingly gaze upon sean connery
shirtless like there's a lot of beats in
these films that are just let's take a
breather to enjoy a shirtless i will say
yeah to the degree that there is nudity
it's very equal opportunity john connery
is is in like the tiniest shorts and no
shirt in in a lot of these um
you know it just tells you like his his
uh his his swag for for lack of a better
word that he wears tiny terry cloth
shorts
and like like a jumper like a little
terry cloth jumper in like two of the
movies and you're like yeah he's cool
that guy looks really good
yeah this guy making it it's like a
powder blue uh like little towel onesie
and you're like damn sean connery was
the [ __ ] yeah it was
a tough guy in modern day films would
not spend nearly as much time in like
health spa type involvement
he's very frequently in just like a robe
like yeah like getting getting like
or not he's in like a bikini wetsuit at
one point like in thunderball like it
covers his upper body but he's in like
little uh wetsuit underwear um yeah like
well daniel craig daniel craig put on
the the tidy whatevers for i mean like
daniel craig there are there are also
scenes in the newborn films showing off
daniel craig's admittedly very
impressive physique as well but i don't
think it's quite as leering as these
were in terms of like connery with his
shirt off which is obviously like was a
major attraction for these movies when
is bond gonna be brave enough to to hang
dong is my question
when are we going to get a bon dong on
screen
thunderdome coming 2024.
dog james dawn um i think the next one
that should be that should be a
requirement at least side hog yeah
anyways that was you know at the end of
the movies it's always like james bond
will return anyway james bond will drop
trow in
thunderdome
all right you play
you know how i know you're an alcoholic
i'd say it was a 30 year old fiend
differently blended sir
with an overdose of bomb
51 i believe there is no year for chevy
double 07. i was referring to the
original vintage on which the sherry is
based 1851 don't stick it i like saki
especially when it's served at the
correct temperature
98.4 degrees fahrenheit like this is and
kobe
got rid of the hat toss yeah this was a
this was like clearly one of the
originals my next miracle
the spy who fought me
[Music]
okay so what's up with the gun barrel
opening i know it's a classic but like
is that what a bullet sees before it
fires and if the guy holding the gun
gets shot why do i see blood dripping
down if we're inside the
gun fun yeah does not make up does not
and i think it's weird that i never
thought about it before but i was like
as i was watching for the honest trailer
i was like wait what are we even seeing
here yeah that's not even james bond um
eventually it is
the first in the first like three or
four movies it is literally a random
person
yeah they were like pov you are james
bond's gun and you're losing a gunfight
with this random guy to pull her out
james bond over there so he wins the
gunfight that would make more
uh anywho um i imagine we have some
deleted scenes though i'm not sure what
is a long trailer but we must cut
something out so let's roll those if we
go
staring
mission impossible the spylander
scotchnag dial m for middle management
penny lane pam i don't know what to do
with my hands a poor helpless man being
psychically controlled by an evil cat
this gold-breaking ass
knock knocks who's there orek orick who
i don't expect you to talk mr bond i'm
quite cracked though
extraordinarily horny gentlemen
bond government bond
am i shakesh
[Laughter]
oh the titles make those well done again
yeah those are above and beyond every
time
all right uh let's get into fan
questions um
are you going to do any of the other
bonds i mean we'll do no time to die i'm
sure uh yeah and we should do someone
else asked uh i've lost for a moment but
are we gonna do every uh roger moore
bond jim one asked that uh yeah i would
love to do every morning certainly
different enough to i mean i think we
could do these for i mean dalton and
lazenby would be tricky because there's
not that many movies but otherwise i
think we could do cool ones for like
every brosnan every browser would be
great yeah i would love to do that so
yeah yeah we'll do it um evan jay
pretzel s uh uh adam west was almost
bonded diamonds are forever would that
have been a great bond or the greatest
bond uh someone else has a similar
question of like people who almost
played james bond that you would have
liked to see
um i just found out that uh uh jim
brolin was uh uh he screen tested for
bond james brolin that's that's
very odd i've never heard him do a
british accent but i'm kind of intrigued
yeah i mean i would have thought
americans would be just like no like
they're just like there's a lot of
americans who have like that kind of
cool swagger you could see doing the
part but it's just so
like you have to be
from at least the commonwealth like god
even if you're not even from england i
mean like they want you to be somewhere
that was once owned by britain yeah it
didn't have like a revolution you would
think um yeah he was a he was a
a dashing young man i could see him as
james bond if he could nail the accent
you know why not well he is um he's pw
herman in the uh peewee's big adventure
big screen adaptation where they turn
him into a super spy well there you go
um yeah
at the end of peewee's big adventure
where they go see the movie that was
made about pee-wee yeah james brolin's
playing pw
wow um and morgan fairchild is uh dottie
oh i see uh would you ever know what i'm
talking about
but
lon do you have an almost bond
[Laughter]
that you would have liked to see oh i
mean i feel like we've all kind of
conceded the point that idris elba is
now like a little long in the tooth and
probably missed his window but he's a
guy that there was a lot of heat behind
that i think would have been a kick ass
james bond yeah agreed
um all right to uh matan valencias uh
after spectre ripped off gold member
do you think austin powers should come
back for an outdated uh but well needed
parody of the dark and gritty bond wave
of the 2000s
wait did how did specter rip off gold
member i don't know maybe they can
elaborate on that yeah i'd love to hear
i'm not saying they it didn't i'm just
curious to hear more
yes
you know when um when uh
what's his name um
the
uh hans landa is that actor
oh christopher christophel yeah he kept
picking his scabs and keeping them in a
little box
he does they hate the dutch so i think
but yes of course i would i would love
for them to try to do a a modern bond
born
mission impossible like like another top
secret basically let's get valkiller to
make top secret again wow great i think
i feel like we're we're only ever one or
two meetings away from the new austin
powers anyway right so this would be a
perfect
thing for them to jump in on maybe
mcgruber is kind of gonna take some of
that i feel like the peacock mcgruber
series might live in this world already
yep
uh oh this is interesting um
well ryan wrote maybe this is a question
from ryan there's no name attached uh
yeah i got brought it up yeah okay in
skyfall they were originally thinking
about bringing connery back as the old
caretaker of the bond estate was it
smart to skip that stunt casting or
would it have been cool i mean that
would have really kicked off the whole
like bond as a code name passed on to
different agents uh fan theory
uh which you know i mean it's explained
it's like the caretaker who knew bond as
a kid he wouldn't have been playing he'd
play the character albert finney plays
yeah
i don't know if it would have been like
he was the old james bond it would have
been a cool way to like kind of just you
know it was just a wink and a nod and if
you go back and watch that he's making
all these kind of like one-liners that
if they maybe thought that was connery
saying they make a lot more sense like
talking about scotland and i don't know
yeah
yeah and mendes and i think you know the
rest of just knew like all right that'd
probably be just a little too
distracting of a stunt casting and all
that kind of stuff so i don't know how
far it ever made but i just knew that
they had talked about that yeah i just
assumed connery said no and we're like
all right that also might be what
they're covering for that he just never
got back for them
we didn't want to
yeah i guess not it would be cool to do
the reunion of the bonds of like you you
do that you'd lean into it like oh was a
code name and here's pierce brosnan sean
connery and roger moore but so many of
them are either dead or disgruntled with
their experience on james bond daniel
craig wouldn't come back pierce brosnan
wouldn't come back like uh i was like
i'm dr fate now i don't need you anymore
i'm an iconic character doctor
just while we're here the the specter
gold member clear up is because the
whole adoptive brother thing the whole
like oh the villain okay
all right i get all right well well sure
enough fair enough all right
well uh that about wraps up bond for us
today uh
super fun to talk about super fun to
rewatch um just uh just a pleasure
compared to some of the other things we
have to watch around here uh because
next week's coming up um it's not bad
but it's definitely evil
so that is your clue for next week's
honest trailer uh
you know will evil make uh make it to
next week or will it die tonight
you be the judge
we'll see you then like if you've seen
the movie you
get that what we're talking about yeah
um so we'll see you then if you haven't
uh if you haven't seen what i'm talking
about maybe give it a watch before then
it's fine uh we'll see you then thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you